attention attention et c'est pour mme
toussaint pas moi j'y vais c'est quoi ça
c'est impossible c'est quoi photo
numérique trouver un point commun et
jean marie le pen
alors un point commun j'ai pris l'avion
pour aller à strasbourg attend d'accord
oui j'ai pris l'avion pour aller à
strasbourg une fois par semaine pendant
que j'étais député européen rebecca
elle a jeté sur vous devez donner tout
l'argent vous avez sur vous à une oeuvre
caritative
j'ai pas une thune
mais je vais me rattraper dans la cadre
demain tu files jeu parmi leurs autres
à combien ces données pour le cachemire
parce que franchement
non mais je te jure que non
les messieurs
la rencontre l'amour allait il fallait
alors celle-là voir s'ils étaient tous à
un souvenir de crédit lyonnais
il est bien